la première élection municipale le débat
madame monsieur bonsoir
bonjour pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
sur internet nous sommes aujourd'hui en
présence de trois candidates et
candidats pour les élections municipales
et communautaires du lorrain le lorrain
le royaume de la banane cette
application nommée cette commune avec un
très grand nombre d'exploitations dédié
à la culture de ce fruit exporté pour
l'essentiel en france en europe
le visiteur est frappé par la puissance
des vagues s'est fracassé sur la longue
plage s'étendant en contrebas du bon
ceux qui sont déjà passés on est loin
peuvent être impressionné par ce
spectacle
cette commune est située je le rappelle
entre marigot aussi des baskets ou non
pour ceux qui n'ont pas l'habitude de
prendre la rn 1
plusieurs garanties rappelle le
caractère rural du lorrain karam un
maximum capot mais il y en ad'autres
nous invitez vous ont peut-être nous en
parler lauret est la troisième commune
par sa superficie de martinique avec les
50 kilomètres carrés 5033 hectares en
plus exactement son premier nom pour
ceux qui s'en souviennent et à grande
anse en référence à cette baie largement
ouverte sur l'atlantique avant qu'elle
ne soit baptisé de son actuelle il ya un
près de deux siècles en 1840 et le
marigot cdh veut est devenue une commune
ans en dh en 1889 leur louerait un
compte aujourd'hui un peu moins de 7000
habitants
mais là a été peuplée jusqu'à 9500
personnes il y a de cela 60 ans elle
reste l'une des communes les plus
peuplées du territoire de cap nord il y
a six mille électrices et électeurs aux
lorrains qui auront à élire 29 membres
du conseil municipal et trois délégués
au conseil communautaire de cap nau
c'est l'une des communes aussi qui
compte depuis 1945 le plus faible nombre
de mes en 3 en l'occurrence joseph
colloque plutôt direct oui j'ai fait la
queue durant trente ans michel talent
même si durant 33 ans est l'actuel
depuis 2008
quelques personnalités natif du lorrain
pour terminer cette présentation les
écrivais raphaël confiant jean bernabé
léonard saint vil il y a également des
personnalités politiques rodolphe des
idées qui est lacunaire du mari natif de
la commune 6100 pétrier anciens
dirigeants socialistes ou encore le
docteur juvénal linval membres
fondateurs du parti communiste et puis
un grand sportif
hugues michaud les karatékas et actuel
en beach international
le karaté je n'oublie pas enfin
d'activités sportives avec le rapid club
et l'océanie club de football lui
rhinoise à football féminin l'éveil de
karameh handball est en fait le nom team
club en natation
je disais tout à l'heure candidates et
candidats puisque nous avons une
candidate en la personne de véronique
panfilo diane bonjour bonsoir madame
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes âgé de 54 ans vous êtes
directrice des finances dans une grande
entreprise privée vous mener la liste
agir pour le lorrain sans étiquette et
vous avez été dans le passé adjointe au
maire actuel de 2008 à 2014 tout à fait
à côté de vous se trouve guy annonay âgé
de 69 ans psychologues de l'éducation
nationale à la retraite
bon sang mais c'est anonyme chargement
merci d'avoir accepté de venir
pour ce dernier de notre de notre série
de débats en radio filmée sur la ligne 1
vont mener la liste sans étiquette
lionel logue tpiy l'yonne et pilote pour
laurens et puis l'autre pôle haut rhin
j'assiste vous êtes conseiller municipal
dans l'opposition vous avez été premier
adjoint au maire de michel calme ainsi
jusqu'en 2008
vous avez également occupé les fonctions
de conseiller général de 2010 à 2015 et
de vice président du conseil régional de
1998 à 2004 vous avez milité à vous êtes
de sensibilité de droite à l'ump puis
surtout à l'union projeté phosphates et
une caisse de congrès avant de vous
détacher de toute formation politique et
de sujets comme non inscrit au conseil
général et enfin juste un bon film on se
remet son fils l'actuel maire du lorrain
candidat à sa propre succession
vous êtes âgé de 50 ans cadre supérieur
de collectivités ou mener la liste
ensemble continuons à construire le
lorrain avec le soutien de votre
mouvement le rfr rassemblement des
fausses lauwinoise vous êtes conseiller
communautaire également cap non
conseillé à la martinique et je rappelle
que vous avez été vice président du
conseil régional de 2010 à 2015
madame monsieur si vous le permettez si
vous le souhaitez nous allons entendre
maintenant quelques lauwinoise et
quelques longues et noir rencontrée au
hasard des rues de cette grande ville
par bien car eto'o pour un micro
trottoir sur lequel je vais vous
demander de réagir par la suite je suis
pas n'était
déjà précédente a déjà commencé pas mal
de travail ou qu'ils continuent le
travail qu'ils ont entamée depuis les
dernières élections totalement la
destruction yvonne catalan et la
reconstruction comme l'église c'était
très attendu pour le stade et tout ça un
marché qui a que deux marches en dedans
je dirais de l'animation de la commune
en allant devant des rockers je ne vois
pas qu'est ce que je vis au bout ce
qu'il n'y a pas de porc qui a renié pour
les enfants beaucoup plus d'activité
beaucoup plus de dynamisation dans la
ville voilà un peu moins de textes si
c'est possible qu'on soit dans une zone
franche parce que certains commerçants
souffrent énormément parce que
l'activité a diminué nommément mais il
faudrait plus des commerces on va dire
où les gens puissent se poser peut-être
commerçants que sans population ça ne
passe pas changement pour les jeunes qui
travaillent sur le toit du loup et à
trouver je plisse des dispositifs pour
les eaux permettent de trouver du
travail il ya des formations qui n'ont
pas grand-chose à au fluo voilà pourquoi
comme tous les jeunes du loup il faut
qu'on aille chercher bien loin aussi qu
il s est pas évident surtout que le
week-end lorsque les voitures mal
stationnées tout était fermé avait des
salles de jeu il y avait dix ans
il faut s'y tenir
voilà madame messieurs si vous avez un
commentaire sur cetet exercice à la
micro tout en un qui est particulier
comme je le disais ça n'a pas valeur de
sondage c'est simplement nos
pérégrinations celle de notre patrie ce
bien karito dans les villes dans l'est
dans les rues de la ville du loing qui a
donné ce résultat du rhône icm en philo
diane d'observation des remarques ce que
vous avez entendu écouté vont se réjouit
noah écouter ce que je crois avoir
entendu en tout cas reflète tout à fait
pour ce qui est notamment de la question
de l'animation des commerces des
problématiques de restauration également
ressemble en tout point à ce que nous
avons pu constater dans notre diagnostic
de territoire organisé avec les citoyens
maintenant j'ai entendu également sur
catalan oui c'est une très belle chose
enfin ce bâtiment soit a soit détruit
j'ai entendu quelques par les deux
bibliothèques donc c'est un problème de
communication je suppose
puisque il y à une bibliothèque aux
lorrains donc voilà donc il ya un
problème de communication en tout cas
pour que l'ensemble des personnes
sachent exactement quelles sont des
services à leur disposition à la en gros
voilà merci de votre observation de vos
observations guy annonay oui bonjour
bonjour l'aubinois j'ai entendu je sens
à travers ce micro-trottoir lille est un
grand désarroi de la population du moins
c'est ce qu'ils se manifestent le besoin
d'une manière réelle sur le terrain où
les habitants du loing ont tendance à
penser avoir le sentiment que rien ne
bouge
rien ne passe c'est une ville morte et
que finalement tout à fait tout est à
refaire tout à tout et à réparer et je
pense que sincèrement que une ville
attractive qui a quand même une grande
capacité puisque nous sommes un bassin
d'emploi de depuis le 15 mai l'habitante
rousse comme avons la ville et les
communes voisines notre basse pointe
marigot ajoupa bouillon est aussi gants
et vierge de baqouba ces personnes ont
tendance à venir sur le loin pour
pouvoir faire leurs courses pouvoir
dépenser il faut avoir de croix pour
permettre à ces personnes
on a entendu aussi que pas mal
d'investisseurs des gens qui ont osé
apporter leur pierre à l'édifice et ils
sont partis ils ont fermé boutique
tout simplement parce qu'il ya un manque
de vigilance et de pouvoir aider de
groote le bouger merci pour vos
observations enfin termine ce premier
temps de réaction avec vous il ne
s'était pas fait le meilleur du lorrain
moi ce que d'abord bonsoir à la
martinique et de manière générale et
puis bonsoir à tous les lots rhinois qui
nous écoutent
j'espère qu'ils sont bien bien attentif
non moi ce que j'ai entendu j'ai à la
fois entendu des constats positifs
et puis de l'espoir
des gens qui ont envie de voir les
choses un peu bouger un peu s'améliorer
par rapport à l'existant moi je crois
que je peux faire regarder ça sous
l'angle de l'espoir quand on me parle
des activités du type restauration la
circulation moi c'est de l'espoir c'est
que la ctm enfin puisse réaliser de fond
de mer je crois que l'espoir c'est faire
en sorte que les salles de jeu ce qu'on
appelait ça le jeu à l'époque existait
qui étaient des sales payante
je pense qu'aujourd'hui l'organisation
de la martinique fait que beaucoup de
professionnels du monde de l'animation
du de des médias se sont centrés le
couple sur l'agglomération
et puis sur ce que les gens attendent
demain de manière globale on va en
parler je suppose tout à l'heure il ya
un travail qui est fait par la ville et
l'idée en tout cas la démarche que nous
avons actuellement clencher de dans le
cadre de cette élection c'est de
poursuivre le travail d'ailleurs juste
par rapport au fait que catalan a été
cité le bâtiment démolition du bâtiment
a commencé aujourd'hui alors justement
inquiet puisque vous en tant que leur
union à vos vous savez très bien de quoi
il s'agit je rappelle simplement que
c'est une école une ancienne école
dénommée yvonne catalan et qui est à
tout à côté de la mairie le bâtiment a
été démoli avec beaucoup de nuisances
sonores dans le coin c'est tout à fait
explicables compréhensible il ya
également des travaux d'élargissement de
la chaussée sur la zone du stade afin
qu'ils passent devant le stand pour
monter je les piétons et c'était assez
vite et la circulation c'est la septième
évidemment qui s'occupe de 7,10 travaux
de cette route nationale
donc ça fait beaucoup de travaux de gêne
occasionnée est ce que les l'aubinois
j'y serai pour le film puisque le tirage
au sort nous a désignés pour commencer
cette série de discussions
est-ce que les lobbys ne le sont pas un
peu agacé énervé impatients de toutes
ces nuisances canton il faut savoir le
centre-bourg faut savoir ce qu'on veut
moi je crois qu'on ne peut pas on ne
peut pas embellir rénové réhabiliter une
ville s'il n'y a pas de nuisances le
bruit la poussière la démolition la
reconstruction est ce qui est le plus
important pour moi c'est pas tant les
nuisances et le résultat final c'est ce
qu'on va obtenir comme satisfaction
la démolition de catalans qui était pour
nous un projet important bien on va
passer 2 3 joue là où il y aura un peu
de bruit un peu de poussière
mais ce qui est le plus important c'est
que les quatorze mois qui vont suivre
sur les quatorze mois où on va
reconstruire le bâtiment
ça vaut également pour le la
l'élargissement de la route de castel
brando ça vaut également pour crochemore
ça vaut pour d'autres voies cité wallon
par exemple nous sommes actuellement en
train de réaliser la voie de
désenclavement du quartier cité wallon
je crois que on ne peut pas imaginer de
de la réhabilitation et du
renouvellement
s'il n'y a pas un peu de nuisances et
s'il n'y a pas de nuisances je suis pas
magicien personne n'est magicien et
forcément on passe par ces étapes là
j'étais question des étapes nécessaires
juste une précision puisqu'il faut
laisser parler tout le monde bien
entendu
qu'est-ce qui va se
qu'est ce qu'il y aura en lieu et place
de cette ancienne école catalan catalan
participent à la rénovation et à la
redynamisation du centre bourg tout le
rez-de-chaussée de catalan ce sont des
commerces de l'activité commerciale donc
le une banque de grande importance qui
va venir s'installer là bas une activité
commerciale type commerces boutiques
type hyper u leclerc tout ce que l'on
veut qu'ils devraient venir également
s'installer la mer c'est qu'aucune
publicité mais oui mais je bonjour ici
et puis les des commerçants du bourg qui
était parti du côté de gilbert tarquin
si c'est leur souhait c'est de revenir
nous avons également réserver des
espaces pour les commerçants qui étaient
déjà là et qui s'ils le souhaitent
pourront revenir et puis en haut du
bâtiment
nous avons également d hervé une partie
pour la résidence pour des personnes de
grand âge pour permettre que dans le
bourg mais que des gens continuent
d'habiter de vivre donc activités
commerciales au rez-de-chaussée et sur
les tâches des logements pour des
personnes seniors des personnes de grand
âge il ironiquement familial 7 ces
travaux comme disait tout à l'heure
monsieur le maire sont des nuisances
certes connaissez nécessaire est ce que
vous pensez qu'on aurait pu faire
autrement ou alors qu'il ya d'autres
priorités
écoutez moi je considère que la question
de l'aménagement du territoire c'est un
c'est une question globale
quand on se pose depuis une douzaine
d'années aujourd'hui la réflexion elle
n'est pas me dit il y a deux mois
c'est une question sur notamment
catalans et d'autres d'autres secteurs
c'est une c'est une question qui a été
posée depuis quand même 10 en 2008
puisque moi j'étais largué 8 je me
souviens quand même des prémices de ce
dossier là s'agissant de la démolition
du bâtiment moi je crois qu'il y a des
précautions supplémentaires à prendre
parce que notamment aujourd'hui
effectivement ça a commencé nous sommes
vraiment très contents il fallait que ça
se fasse toute façon mais il y à des
protections à m et on ne peut pas sur un
bâtiment où il y a eu quand même
de la miotte démolir comme ça c'est à
dire que il y a quand même des
précautions à prendre même s'il y a eu
des interventions par ailleurs
d'entreprises spécialisées et que aussi
il y a eu quelques dérapages puisque des
agents se sont retrouvés sur ce chantier
sans protection alors qu'il y a quand
même de l'amiante et qui n'ont rien à y
faire
moi je crois que il y à des précautions
supplémentaires à faire ça c'est une
chose la deuxième chose s'agissant de la
destination du bâtiment qui sera
construit
moi je n'ai en tout cas moi je n'ai pas
participé à aucun moment à une rencontre
avec la population je n'ai jamais été
invité à ce genre de rencontre pour
justement débattre de l'avenir
effectivement de ce bâtiment stade il
est ce qu'il y à une enquête pour les
municipales n'est pas compétent à
prendre moi je considère qu'aujourd'hui
en tout cas dans ce siècle que nous
vivons le conseil municipal la
constitution donne justement cette
possibilité d'avoir une cette
représentation
mais cette représentation ne se limite
pas et c'est inscrit dans la
constitution le site royer a aussi
d'ailleurs on inscrit bien des conseils
de quartier ou autre donc ce que moi je
dis en réalité bon alors que moi je n'ai
pas été formés parce que peut-être je
n'étais pas là enfin j'en sais rien mais
en tout cas la destination véritablement
du bâtiment météo peine quand j'entends
qu'il y aura des logements par exemple
juste à côté de l'église
je ne suis pas certaine que des
logements vont les mounier qu'a fait
ricco juge suit l'homme escale et en
fait bon bref j'essaie de d'imaginer
l'ambiance qui pourrait être y avoir
dans cette dans cet espace là et les
commerces quel type de commerce alors
quand j'entends par exemple un
hypermarché hyper wii ou leclerc ou
n'importe lequel sans vouloir faire de
la publicité
oui c'est un exemple mais il n'empêche
que il y a quand même un casino
qui entraîne fermé qui en train de
souffrir il y à un autre un autre centre
à séguinaud qui est ouvert il bon il y
en a encore un autre un écho maxi en
train de fermer en fait qui en train de
chercher un repreneur
donc est ce que c'est ce type de
commerce dont nous avons besoin sa vie
qu'il ya une véritable réflexion à mener
sur le type de commerce à développer aux
lorrains avec les commerçants qui existe
là aussi je pose la même question mais
je finis juste là aussi je m'interroge
sur la propriété de ce bâtiment qui est
le propriétaire véritablement de ce
bâtiment parce qu'il y aura des loyers
d'ailleurs qui seront pour notamment les
commerçants ils seront à quel montant
fin donc je me pose quand même ces
questions là mais juste une question
avant de passer à monsieur and honey qui
sera propriétaire de ce matin la ville
est propriétaire du terrain et nous
avons signé un bail emphytéotique avec
la semsamar jeu mais je voudrais paris
pour de manière aussi rapide parce que
je voudrais qu'on a plusieurs petites
choses mais je m adapte à des menaces
étaient des sports pour le team
militaires eux mêmes utilisent puisque
mathieu 6 passes partiez à la ville il y
a un bail emphytéotique qui a été signé
avec la semsamar et le bâtiment
redeviendra la propriété de la ville ce
sont des choses qui se font
régulièrement donc il n'y a aucune forme
d'extraordinaire dans le mode de
réalisation du bâtiment alors je reviens
vers vous qui a donné je vous demander
votre opinion sur la démolition mais en
tout cas
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait et qu'est ce
qu'il aurait fallu faire est ce que
c'est un bon choix la municipalité que
d'avoir transformé cette ancienne école
en centre d'affaires et un immeuble de
logements ou alors vous pensez qu'on
aurait pu à qu'il aurait pu avoir une
autre destination comme disait mais je
vous dis que je suis placé sous une
autre logique où l'humain devait être au
coeur de nos préoccupations
là où je trouve quand même difficile à
croire et à penser quid de ce que vient
de dire madame en file indienne mais
surtout de
de dire dans quelle misère même si il
faut faire des sacrifices
l'accalmie zea se trouve au centre où v
les commerçants du lorrain a travaillé à
cette expérience
voyez je peux le dire comme ça d'une
manière froide bien voilà si on veut
faire avancer les choses mais on n'a
qu'à souffrir
et bien moi de mon côté je dis non je
dit autre chose que tout cela je dis que
ça se prépare
mais en accompagne évidemment les
commerçants qui sont dans la souffrance
que vous avez entendu dans le micro ce
d'autant que beaucoup de personnes sont
parties n'ont pas été accompagnés mais
il y a un dispositif avec la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de la martinique
pour prévoir le mans que le manque à
gagner de ces commerçants qui ont été
privés depuis de nombreux mois ne peut
pas avoir accès ou les clients ne peut
pas avoir accès aujourd'hui ce qu'est le
plus grave
et bien il y avait une poussière immense
ce qu'on peut concevoir mais qu'on
pouvait préparer en a autant un peu plus
en essayant de préparer les personnes
mais je crois que ceux qui pourront
manquer il ya beaucoup de précipitations
elles avaient des campagnes électorales
voyons que des panneaux de chantier un
peu partout à droite à gauche ça
m'étonne et puis le moment où commencer
les travaux
fort de dénigrement que j'ai eu
l'occasion de le faire et en disant que
ça suffit maintenant il faut aller un
peu plus loin
bon alors si vous ce plan là il faut
t'il comme en font foi qu'il aménager ou
réaménager le centre bon qui est
quittera long comme on notera c'est ça
fait quasiment 2 km de long de zone
urbaine comment font-ils le dessiner au
le redessiner d'après vous puisqu'il
n'ya pas que ce bâtiment là c'est une
question d'aménagement plus globale vous
prendrez vous dites qu'il mettre
l'humain au centre de la politique
publique de la municipalité mais encore
bien il y a beaucoup de concertation
avoir posé la masia nourrir il y a
beaucoup de procès d'intention à voir
avec notamment les habitants avec les
commerçants discuter avec eux essayez de
trouver à quel moment qu'il faut
entreprendre ces travaux peut-être
jusqu'à pouvoir demander aux entreprises
d'intervenir peut-être le soir pour
pouvoir permettre à ces personnes de
pouvoir bénéficier de tous je dis que
effectivement je suis le premier à dire
que ce bout là méritent d'être
revitalisé mérite de donner beaucoup
plus d'attractivité à notre commune je
le souhaite je l'espère et je ne ferai
que ça pour permettre aux lorrains dans
d'obtenir le lustre d'antan 1
ça c'est important mais jeudi on ne peut
pas d'une manière froide en disant parce
qu'il ya des élections caribe mais il
faut aller vite il faut précipité mais
je vous ai dit c'est pas nous la
démolition parce que je n'ai même pas vu
de permis de démolition
j'ai vu de construction mais ce panneau
que se trouvait là depuis rares et de
l'autre élections de l'an dernier
c'était là le panneau s'est effrité
alors je ne sais pas très bien à
l'élection de 2014 de 2014
on a vu dès maintenant pouvoir dire le
bon voilà tout a commencé
les panneaux le temps de se dérouiller
tombé à l'abandon et aujourd'hui nous
croyons brusquement et un coup de pioche
en bas des choses
quelle est la destinée qu est ce qu il
ya de la franchise de dents ou un peu
croire à avoir de la crédibilité de quoi
un peu cette vie là je vous dis je suis
assez sceptique et j'ose croire que les
choses ne vont pas s'arrêter une fois
que on a cassé le bâtiment ça c'est
important
alors monsieur le meilleur du lorrain
justin pamphile voilà vous organisez des
travaux quelques semaines quelques mots
je le demande les élections municipales
je me demande s'il faut leur répondre à
tous les deux parce qu'en réalité fait
setting et puis bon de dire que chaque
fois qu'il parle on a l'impression
qu'ils se sont mis d'accord pour
organiser leurs réponses faire le
travaux le soit mais à la rigueur mais
c'est terrible à dire que si une
nuisance le matin mais faire les travaux
le soir et des eaux pour qu'il y ait
encore plus de nuisances et de faire en
sorte que les gens dorment les gens se
reposent
c'est à ce moment là qu'il faut démolir
le bâtiment d'ailleurs bâtiment qui
l'avait présenté comme étant un bâtiment
sur lequel il y avait un projet je
rappelle à monsieur anoh n'est que le
bâtiment telles que je les trouvais s'il
lui qui me l'a laissé puisqu'il était là
pendant une trentaine d'années
demandez à votre ami michel tellement
c'est pourquoi s'embêter les gens
seraient était maire arrêtez avec ça
allait me fait pas rire les images
exemple je demanderai à monsieur a donné
ce qu'il a fait pendant les 30 dernières
niveau il était là pendant trente ans le
bâtiment était là pendant trente ans il
n'a absolument rien fait aucune
destination et aucun projet et vous vous
trompez sur l'amitié de michel talent
mais si voilà ça candidat qui est juste
en face et madame diane qui ne soutient
pas madame par philous diane s'il vous
madame confie lousiane qu'il soutient
pas moi et partant de ce principe là si
vous avez une question à s'il ya un
problème avec michel d'un messie poser
la question madame pas fait pas à moi
pour ce qui me concerne pour ce qui me
concerne ce bâtiment gelé répétait je le
répète c'est un bâtiment sur lequel il y
a un projet le montage financier c'est
pas un montage qui se fait d'un
claquement de doigts il faut que la nba
soit mobiliser parce qu'il ya du
logement il faut que le fisac soient
mobilisés parce qu'il ya des commerces
et ce sont des choses qui prennent du
temps ça c'est une chose
la deuxième chose c'est que elle dit je
n'ai jamais été invité je n'ai mais il
aurait fallu qu'elle soit présente
jamais présente d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs je me rappelle qu'elle disait
à qui voulait l'entendre dans ses
interviews que depuis 2010 je n'était
déjà plus là où raul et dont nous
discutions de la construction et de la
reconstruction du bâtiment
quand vous n'êtes pas là il ya un
principe simple qui dit que les absents
ont toujours tort donc à partir du
moment où vous n'êtes pas là alors que
vous êtes adjointe au maire vous
bénéficiez d'une délégation
vous avez une indemnité vous ne venez
pas vous n'êtes pas présente mais bien
qu il ya quelque chose que je ne
comprends pas mais comme on peut
bénéficier du nez et je ne lui ai pas
enlever la délégation volontairement
parce que je crois que quand on est
quand on s'engage en politique il faut
aller jusqu'au bout et je finis
concernant l'amiante
le bâtiment était correctement des
amiantés vers jamais le bâtiment étaient
calfeutrés dans les règles de l'art
l'entreprise qui est venue des amendes
des amiantés est une entreprise qui est
assermenté agréé ya jamais eu de de
jeudi et puis monsieur a donné 10 les
commerçants ont souffert la ville a
organisé une opération tiroir qui a
permis que tous les commerçants qui
étaient à catalans ont été tous relogés
à gilberte harquet ya pas un commerçant
qui restait sur le carreau non je ne
sais pas de quoi il parle je ne
comprends pas et pour finir pour finir
j'ai pas voulu tout à l'heure si
et sur cette ue catalan je pas insisté
j'ai pas voulu citer encore bien ça avec
lequel nos grandes discussions
les commerçants qui sont censés
retourner à catalans se sont tous des
commerçants du lorrain met
volontairement je n'ai pas voulu donner
le nom des commerces avec lequel nous
sommes aux discussions parce que ça
serait trop facile qu'ils prennent leur
bâton demain matin et qu'ils haïssent et
couvrir ces commerçants de leur dire de
ne pas y aller puisque c'est ce qu'on
fait à longueur de journée il y a un
commerce actuellement au loin allez je
peux le site et cactus avec qui on est
en grande discussion pour lui permettre
de se déplacer de venir je suis aux
catalans donc pour moi vous savez quand
je les entends j'ai l'impression que on
ne vit pas dans la même ville je l' ai
déjà dit je le répète catalan est une
activité c'était un bâtiment sur lequel
il ya une réflexion depuis un long
moment longtemps nous avons consultés
nous avons pris le temps et sur la
question de la démolition aujourd'hui eh
bien oui effectivement il y avait de la
poussière mais comme je dis je ne les ai
pas dit froidement je les dis de manière
réelle vient pas il n'y a pas deux fois
l'heure de dire quand on dit que pour
que l'on soit belle ou que l'on soit
jolie qu'il faut faire des efforts et
qu'il faut quelquefois subir des
difficultés
il n'y a pas deux fois une heure là
c'est simplement la réalité de la vie et
ça vous devriez le savoir après trente
années passées à exercer là en étant
première estime ainsi on peut s'en
excuser moi mais si tu as une très
important parce que quand j'entends que
c'est un bail emphytéotique
oui c'est un bail emphytéotique mais il
faut savoir aussi qu'un bail
emphytéotique ce n'est pas sur cinq ans
il faut que les gens comprennent ce
qu'est ce que ça veut dire emphytéotique
d'accord donc quelles qu'elles soient
les revenus qu'ils reviennent à la ville
en tout cas d'incendié par une facile
donc la location ira aux propriétaires à
ceux qui n'y ont dû récemment ce ne sera
pas la ville c'est faux ce ne sera pas
la ville ça c'est une chose
la deuxième chose c'est du mépris de
divo mission continuité et ben ils se
concertent
absolument c'est du n'importe quoi si
c'est du mépris et puis évidemment quand
vous entendez absente depuis 2010 je dis
que c'est du n'importe quoi 1 parce que
évidemment si vous êtes absente pendant
un moment et que vous revenez
mais il n'en demeure pas moins que j'ai
quand même amené un agent d'arrêter en
délibération 2012 donc il aurait fallu
que je ne sois pas là depuis 2010 est
parti définitivement
donc c'est un peu n'importe quoi et et
mon nom il suffit de prendre n'importe
quel délibération de la ville et on
vivra bien à quel moment j'ai été prise
on voit qu'elle moi j'étais absente
alors aux trois questions propres qui
n'est pas propre au loin mais qui est
assez frappante quand on traverse le
bourg c'est le nombre de maisons qui
tombe en ruine quasiment alors c'est la
division qui comme dans toutes les
communes de martinique pose un problème
de réhabilitation de restauration de de
remodelage du centre-ville et 6 ans est
frappant dans la grande rue là là oui
cher la lentilla central qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour modifier les choses
archives accueillent à la loi le
chimiste la division qui permet
maintenant à des indivisaires adecco
indivis de se mettre d'accord à la
majorité seulement alors qu'avant
c'était à l'unanimité dont pour
accélérer les choses mais c'est quand
même guy annonay ça ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui s'adaptent pas de 5 ans 6
en 10 ans ces deux maisons qui tombe en
ruine ce sont des dossiers très anciens
d'après vous est-ce que vous avez une
idée un projet dans ce sujet miloudi
ancien mais qui perdure et qui se
dégrade de plus en plus sous le regard
indifférent à deux mères qui n'est
jamais présent mais pertinent permettez
moi de vous dire c'est très important
et de rappeler à monsieur profil que il
a toujours tendance à pouvoir répondre
soit mode de division et c'est
d'ailleurs la même façon que vous
m'insultez monsieur a donné quand vous
m'insultez garder vos leçons pour vous
quand vous monsieur le tyrannosaure non
non je n'ai pas de leçon à recevoir de
ce monsieur il passe son temps à
m'insulter à m'insulter
et là il veut me parler de division
gardez vos leçons pour vous je vais pas
citer si ce qu'il dit de moi dans les
zones sous les ondes et d'ailleurs je
vais publier ce qu'il dit sur les ondes
pour grignoter votre soif et en me
parlant de des visions quand il passe
son temps à m'insulter et je répète et
je perds six essais de la même année à
chaque fois qu'il répond son
comportement un peu volage sous le mode
de la dérision était la même façon que
sur tous les terrains et voilà les
mauvais résultats du lorrain alors nous
avons un meilleur
à une commune mais qui s'est isolée du
contexte géopolitique de l'eau et de la
martinique c'est à dire où effectivement
nous avons constaté toujours en conflit
en conflit avec quatre morts ce qui
pénalise énormément nos projets de
permettre aux lorrains d'avancé en
conflit avec notamment la cité m6 que
maintenant ou des raisons d'aller on
essaie de trouver en étant en conflit
même avec des partis pour dire qu'ils
ont portés comme le ppm en conflit avec
même les personnes de son conseil
municipal et bien je vous dis
sincèrement le lot on ne peut pas
avancer parce qu'il faut avoir une
posture
une manière de pouvoir dire des choses
correctement mais ça va se rassembler et
de pouvoir permettre leur est d'avancer
et d'apporter le projet est présent à
chaque institution et non pas boycotter
tout ce que l'auteur même avec notamment
la mission locale de la kbc à la mission
locale du nord surtout encore en conflit
alors est ce que vous croyez avant tout
de pouvoir trouver des solutions des
opportunités des alliances ou permettent
dérange de projets bien évidemment et
bien je vous dis que c'est seulement le
lourd est privé de cela et nous nous
montrons ridicule à travers la
martinique ça c'est important de le
signaler si ce n'est pas un film home de
conflit j'espère je veux pas répondre à
ça je sais pas de quoi ils parlent
parce qu'enfin lente et alors pour les
identifications l'arabe il sait jamais
de quoi on parle lorsqu'il est acculé et
c'est la vérité je vais lui répondre
mais mieux répondre cap non je vois pas
où il ya des conflits avec un pneu
le président qu'à plonger à cap nord il
gère ses affaires avec son bureau et les
choses se font un frais devanture
merdias présenté il ya pas de problème
je participe aux réunions de cap non je
n'ai jamais d'ailleurs je vote je vote
les décisions a souvent à cap nord la
seule décision que je n'ai pas voté à
cap nord c'est le transfert de l'eau à
l'asm et je me suis opposé à cette
décision là parce que les conditions et
les modalités de ce transfert ne me
semblait pas les plus est clair que deux
qui existait donc je me suis opposé à ça
mais sur les autres dossiers qui sont
présentés je les votes à la ctm
je vois pas où je m'oppose là c'est un
métal mois en conflit avec moi que quand
on regarde au lorrain les travaux qui se
font à la ctm de la ctm sous le lorrain
c'est assez extraordinaire
la traversée du bourg la route du stade
le la route du côté de de macédoine sur
la rd 22 le choisir le lot 1 comme étant
une ville pilote en matière de fibre
optique et c'est ça qui fait qu'on est
fâché avec la 7ème et quand je suis à la
ctm ma posture et ma position c'est de
dire je ne m'oppose pas aux décisions
qui sont présentés à la ctm plus souvent
que rarement je m'abstiens notamment sur
le vote du budget le compte
administratif je suis un peu plus c'est
totalement différent par contre sur les
autres que décision n'y a pas de conflit
avec la 7ème et puis pour le ppm
je n'ai pas de conflit avec le pp le
muguet conflit avec moi parce que j'ai
fait le choix simplement d'avoir eu
l'audace d'invités alfred marie jeanne à
la présentation de ma candidature mais
je ne suis pas ni le jouet ni celui à
qui on donne la fessée je suis en année
on ne donne pas la fessée est
aujourd'hui pour chats qui me concerne
je suis libre je suis un homme libre
les seuls le seul patron que j'ai ce
sont les électeurs du laurens et la
population du lorrain je n'accepterai
jamais qu'un parti politique vient de me
dire ce qu'il y a affaire aux lorrains
et si j'ai pris mes distances avec ce
parti c'est simplement parce que je
considère que les modalités de
fonctionnement avec ce parti mais pas
qu'eux ne correspondait pas à ma
conception de la liberté et c'est tout
je ne suis en conflit avec personne
peut-être que le fait de dire les choses
jane et puis une dernière chose et si
aujourd'hui soutiennent madame pamphile
ou diane c'est parce que je suis parti
parce que si j'étais là il mourrait
soutenu un homme profite lousiane je
reviens à l'habitat indigne division qui
est une véritable problématique à
l'échelle de la martinique et du nom
qu'est ce que vous souhaiteriez faire
pour corriger cette situation parce que
vraiment vous êtes d'accord avec moi
quand vous traversez la rue schoelcher
ans animé qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
le désert c'est l'hécatombe
et je précise que ce n'est pas ça ça
révèle justement cette difficulté en
termes
ima sion et d'anticipation parce que les
gens s'en vont tout simplement il n'y a
pas de reprise
donc il faut pouvoir accompagner les
personnes notamment ceux qui sont dans
les divisions il faut pouvoir les réunit
il faut pouvoir leur expliquer comment
faire justement pour reprendre
possession du bien
le cas échéant mais je crois que bon
aujourd'hui nous avons différents
problèmes différents projets notamment
sur le rachis mais je crois qu'il faut
aussi réfléchir autrement à dire qu'il
faut pourquoi pas imagine imaginez
initié une coopérative immobilière
participative donc avec les
propriétaires de façon à pouvoir leur
donner une autre destination
parce que vous vous rendez compte
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des personnes
qui sont parties du lorrain et
aujourd'hui ils ne sont pas dans ces
logements là ils vivent dans d'autres
dans d'autres maisons sur l'ensemble du
territoire ou ailleurs et ils ont la
taxe sur les logements vacants en plus
donc ils ont la taxe foncière ils sont
la taxe sur les logements vacants et
j'en ai même rencontré ya pas que le
bout il ya aussi la campagne parce que
quand je vais dans la campagne je
rencontre certaines personnes qui ont
laissé leurs maisons parce que il n'ya
pas de lumière parce qu'ils sont isolés
parce que ils ne se sentent pas visiter
il considère qu'il n'y a pas de contact
avec la municipalité actuelle qu'ils
laissent leur maison pour partir vivre
dans les logements sociaux
et quand il parle vivent dans les
logements sociaux ils se retrouvent
justement avec cette fameuse taxe sur
les logements vacants
non il faut quand même anticipé le
problème il faut parce que ce sont des
maisons aussi qu'ils vont se détériorer
dont la question de la réflexion sur
l'aménagement global du territoire il
faut là il faut poser il faut poser la
question mais aussi avec la population
il faut les amener dans cette dans ce
débat permanent dans cette discussion
permanente et il ne faut pas simplement
se contenter de garder son dossier son
projet dans son petit coin dans son dans
sa commission urbanisme notamment mais
il faut livrer le projet à la population
il faut faire participer les gens pour
justement réadapter et il faut aussi que
le projet répondait justement aux
attentes de la population parce que vous
pouvez faire autant de bâtiments que
vous voulez mais après qu'est ce que
vous mettez dedans comment vous fait
vivre les gens c'est quoi l'animation
c'est quoi le lien en âge c'est quoi la
mixité sociale que vous créiez c'est ça
qui est important est fondamentalement
je crois comme vous avez parlé de
projets mais justement
s'il y en a parlé de donner des moyens
tour de table chacun
c'est une habitude qu'il faut c'est ce
qui anime un peu inférieur à ce qu'on
perd son étoile
s'écriait un problème permettra de vous
dire sur la question vous est posée
aussi bien de l'avantagé que pourrait
voter la loi letchimy que que
personnellement je dis c'est une avancée
puisque jeu ce texte a été voté la
limite à l'unanimité à l'assemblée
nationale effectivement elle vous dire
qu'il y avait des outils avant il faut
pas dans la rolls jimmy bleu vert et a
le droit de préemption urbain quelque
chose d'extraordinaire qui a toujours
existé et que le maire pamphile fait fi
de ce doigt ne l'avait pas fait
qu'est-ce que c'est le droit de
préemption que c'est expliqué c'est la
possibilité de permettre à la commune
d'avoir sur un télémètre qui se trouve
depuis je peux vous développez mais du
lot ça t'arrive à formuler et ça
commence depuis séguinaud à chaque fois
qu'il y à un terrain qu une maison à
vendre que le maire a la possibilité de
faire l'acquisition et de faire des
projets pour le lot 1
je ne vous dis pas qu il a vendu tous
les bas de de meubles de la ville et que
finalement les et foncières nous avons
absolument rien il a dilapidé les
réserves foncières de loin s'il est un
projet que notamment l'état ou notamment
là c'était à vous de faire ça c'est
foutu n'y a pas de réponse heures et
permettra le voodoo aussi il y à ce
qu'on appelle la loi pour permettre
d'aller sous des sifi des édifices
menaçant wind et là on à ce dispositif
et lorsque on a eu l'occasion puisque
veut faire référence à ce travail que
j'ai eu le cas c'est le faire avec toute
ma détermination et l'amour que je porte
pour cette population là et bien là ce
qu'on nous avons crié notamment le
développement social du quartier
pavillon c'est près de trappes logements
que nous sommes arrivés à pouvoir régler
gérer pour permettre somatiques mandat
voire une loin leurs produits n'avons à
l'entrée de loin
un logement bhatti qui était tout à fait
dans un état d'insalubrité qui était
notamment logement qui appartenait à feu
joseph serlin est bien de ça aussi nous
avons utilisé cet outil que nous avons
qui était la loire pour permettre
notamment de pouvoir l'intervalle sous
les édifices menaçant ruine
on a des outils mais il faut être là
présent il s'agit pas de venir de faire
du verbiage à chaque campagne électorale
à chaque fois qu'il ya des élections qui
s'approche et aujourd'hui on entend en
entraînant d'enrouler la population du
lorrain en disant voilà j'ai sage et ça
déjà on attend par n'a pas besoin que
l'alchimie pour pouvoir faire avancer le
lot deux motions ça un mot se sont fait
la voix de ses voyages aux aux projets
des candidats quand je vous dis qu'il
passe son temps à insulter là maintenant
je fais du verbiage mais c'est pas grave
je suis à donner mon vieux bien je dois
vous gêne énormément d'autres groupes
n'ont pas copié ainsi que je n'aurais
jamais âge mon verbiage doivent leur âge
et vous simplement revenir rapidement
je veux revenir rapidement sur la je
veux revenir je veux revenir rapidement
sur la réhabilitation du centre bourg
effectivement il ya des propriétaires
qui sont effectivement parti depuis un
certain nombre d'années
il ya de l'indivision il ya des gens qui
n'arrivent pas à se mettre d'accord pour
réparer ou vendre des maisons
la question de la préemption oui mais la
préemption l'expropriation les édifices
menaçant ruine ce sont souvent des des
procédures qui sont à la fois l'autre
qui ne se font pas comme ça et qui
quelquefois sont relativement violente
quand vous présentez sur un bâtiment
vous déposséder une famille totalement
de son bien et moi j'ai fait un choix
qui était différent c'est de discuter
avec les familles pour preuve depuis
je suis en discussion avec une famille
qui a un édifice au milieu du bourg dans
le coeur du beau pour lui dire de le
réhabiliter
mais malgré les promesses qui me sont
faites par la famille malgré le fait que
je laisse ma porte ouverte pour essayer
de trouver des solutions avec ces deux
familles je n'y arrive pas mais je vais
te le parce que c'est compliqué parce
qu'ils voient leur notaire qui
n'arrivent pas à se mettre d'accord sur
des partitions etc
je reviens rapidement sur la
dilapidation des biens rapidement la
dilapidation des biens mais dites moi
quel bien j'ai dilapidé le terrain de
fonds de lacs revient c'est vous qui
l'avait vendu 600 milles le sait vous
qu'il avait vendu pour un promoteur
immobilier
c'est par mois le terrain les terrains
on a construit des logements ce sont des
propriétaires privés qui ont vendu à des
bailleurs sociaux
d
dt raid qu'ils avaient qui l'on
souhaitait au construire à ces guides à
macédoine à maxime avivé la ville a
vendu un terrain oui celui de vives et
225 mon repos aviv et c'était 2 0
s'il vous plaît sims et le terrain maría
ses intérêts qui a été vendue par un
privé
c'est ce que j'ai dit le terrain de
macédoine c'est un terrain privé donc la
ville fait quand il s'agit bonrepaux et
maxime il ya des logements qui ont été
construits
le curé de méchas bateau c'est bon repos
le terrain de maxime c'est le terrain
maria je n'ai pas dis des mensonges vous
voulez me faire dire des choses que je
ne dis pas non vous n'avez sur votre
assise et je tenais à préciser non parce
qu'elle vivait c'était la réserve
foncière de la ville comme ces guides
je les ai un foncier acquis était
baptisée place du 22 mai et qui n'a
jamais eu unique destination que de
vendre du sable et du béton
aujourd'hui nous en avons un système
nous en avons fait il ne vais dire nous
en avons fait une résidence pour une
quarantaine d'habitants et nous lui
avons donné le nom de manteau et une
dame qui a compté sur le territoire et
je finis chioula rhs la partie
résorption de l'habitat insalubre
nous n'avons pas attendu la rh hideux
pavillon a été porté par cap non à
l'époque par le civ mano et puis ensuite
par la ccnm nous la ville aujourd'hui
nous avons une opération de résorption
de l'habitat insalubre
nous avons trouvé une solution avec les
services de l'état dans les options de
l'habitat spontané donc surtout
franchement franchement au cauchemar au
bas et on redoute pour un volume de 6
millions 7,2 travaux nous avons commencé
d'ailleurs nous avons commencé les
travaux passe devant chez lui
donc il peut pas dire qu'il ne voit pas
ces travaux là puisque nous reprenons
tout la chaussée qu'ils avaient
abandonné donc partant de ce principe là
6 millions 5 de travaux nous allons
commencer par franchement et nous allons
continuer sur les autres zones où ils
effectivement les maisons sont en état
d'abandon votre parole sans équilibre et
m'a dit on enrichit nos poursuivants
pour les dix dernières minutes de notre
illusion avec le projet madame
ironiquement fils vienne le projet phare
celle qui vous tient le plus à coeur au
salut que vous souhaiteriez voir grey
s'est conclue en priorité quel serait-il
évidemment il y en a plein mais parce
que les projets je les ai pas choisis
moi c'est avec la population en fait les
citoyens qui ont participé aux
différentes rencontres que nous les
avons identifiés mais s'il fallait
vraiment que je retiens un qui en tout
cas est important je considère
considérant la situation liée aux
pesticides du lorrain ce serait le plan
communal santé et c'est un projet qui
permettrait justement d'une part de
pouvoir travailler avec les agriculteurs
les accompagner dans les nouvelles
mamans
comment dire dans les nouvelles
pratiques culturelles mais aussi les
amener à rentrer dans de nouvelles
cultures
parce que vous savez banane can oui mais
jusqu'à quand et il faut anticiper
parce que les gros planteurs eux ils
anticipent déjà donc il faut accompagner
les petits planteurs et des agriculteurs
de manière globale à entrer dans nos
nouvelles pratiques dans de nouvelles
méthodes parce qu on l'aurait il y à
déjà ceux qui ont déjà en boîte il pas
mais ils ne sont pas suffisamment
nombreux
il faut également pouvoir accompagner en
termes d'éducation et de sensibilisation
notamment
et puis insister sur le volet santé
pensent que évidemment nous savons bien
toutes les difficultés qu'il y a autour
de cela mais en terme de projet il y a
deux projets qui sont extrêmement
important parce que notamment sur la
culture et le sport nous avons quand
même deux projets qui sont extrêmement
importants sur ces deux volets là qui
sont vraiment capital pour justement
créé cette économie de la culture et
cette économie du sport et qui permettra
justement de générer une certaine
richesse est ce que le fait que la
population baisse au loin comme ailleurs
évidemment comme je disais tout à
l'heure il ya un recensement de 1961
organisé par l'insee la commune compte 1
5625 ses licences comment fait-on pour
stabiliser ce déjà travaillé avec son
pognon depuis voulait trouver où sont
nos vies mais déjà ceux qui sont là il
faut pouvoir les maintenir et en les
maintenant c'est justement avec les
projets justement sur la culture et sur
le sport il faut aller chercher il faut
il faut faire ce lien
avec les écoles parce que vous savez
quand on a fait notre rencontre
citoyenne autour du sport on nous
faisait remarquer qu effectivement les
associations ne sont pas soutenues des
associations sportives ne sont pas
soutenus il n'y a pas de subventions
pour les associations
bon les explications sur cela il faut
aller le chercher dans le mode de
gestion le mode de gouvernance de la
collectivité
maintenant il faut aussi anticiper sur
la désaffection de ses associations et
des bénévoles qui accompagnent les
enfants et autres
donc il faut pouvoir les valoriser donc
nous avons imaginé également une méthode
pour les valoriser
mais il faut aussi travailler avec les
écoles de façon à ne pas laisser
justement les enfants choir comme ça
pourquoi parce que vous avez des comment
dire des zones d daisy lowe de logements
sociaux un peu partout il y a des gens
qui vivent paisiblement et qu'ils
veulent ils vivent paisiblement mais il
ya également des risques
vous avez des problématiques grave qui
se pose notamment sur la cité de
séguinaud et qui se posent déjà aussi
sur la cité de vive et où et qui sait
eric récemment posé sur la cité de mon
repos donc vous avez comme ça des îlots
vous avez des usines à gaz qui vont
exploser un peu partout il faut
anticiper et donc l'anticipation se fait
également dans ce lien nage avec les
associations la collectivité et les
écoles pour pouvoir accompagner les
enfants parce que les parents aussi ont
besoin d'avoir cet espace de vie
paisible c'est la dernière ligne droite
de notre émission avec les candidats du
lorrain guy annonay quel est le projet
phare celui qui vous tient le plus à
coeur que vous souhaiteriez voir mission
chantier mise en chantier le plus vite
possible
nature et vous monsieur monsieur partie
j'ai du mal à pouvoir rouler pour un ami
mais parce que vous l'aurez toute cette
affaire vue diffèrent et un projet
social la population s'appauvrit
énormément et il faut trouver les moyens
pouvoir donner vie pour permettre à
cette fois cette population de vie
apporter de l'oxygène et ce n'est que
par l'aspect social que nous devons
débattre et on doit permettre à cette
population de pouvoir subvenir à leurs
besoins mais ne pourra tenir les deux
bouts
chaque année et de créer se voulait une
mixité sociale c'est très important
c'est dans ce domaine où j'excelle et
que je crois qu'il ne faudrait pas que
j'ai l'abandonnent notamment continué
peut-être à mettre en place une monnaie
sociale complémentaire de mettre en
place une plateforme de mobilité sociale
etc
mais il ya un autre projet qui me tient
à coeur et j'ai depuis longtemps je les
pentes et je voulais pour l'entendre
le centre d'animation et
d'interprétation de la culture
précolombienne
c'est quelque chose qui apportera de la
plus value au niveau du nord de la
martinique et ça va permettre de faire
des échanges et je suis fort étonné de
privée s'est pressée mais sa leçon de
vives et si vous voulez faire de
financement avec créneau avec cap nau
avec la cité mais avec l'europe et je
crois que il faut être là en fait
présent il faut matraque et il faut ce
qu'est ce ce projet opérationnel mais
cette mesure d'acheter le terrain ça
fait déjà longtemps depuis 12 ans s'est
endormi on n'a pas absolument rien
parfois on entend une petite
communication sexe etc
mais sur le bord du lourd est de pouvoir
créer à travers ce set
ce projet de redynamisation du centre
beau de pouvoir créer des lieux de vie
parce que nous n'avons pas des lieux de
vie des lieux des changes où la
population se retrouvent pour échanger à
chaque fois qu'il y avait un lieu de vie
des choses c'est juste un petit rebord à
côté de la maison des gens s'asseyaient
et j'en discutais les gens parlaient les
gens pouvoir les changer et le long
avait l'air d'avoir toujours quelqu'un
des gens qui se trouvaient là mais c'est
moi où il ya plus de lieux de vie on a
tout cassé
ils sont venus une ville fouad alors ce
projet que je suis entré je pourrais
vous donner d'autres de les permettre
aux enfants de la maternelle d'avoir
accès aux petits déjeuners gratuits et
des secours du 7 % de bio dans la
restauration scolaire le monde
associatif ou effectivement vous l'avez
dit si bien avec le rapide que les v2
carabins avec bien évidemment l'océanie
club le monde rapport même s'ils avaient
des derbys assez musclé mais nous
constatons qu'il y avait de la vie dans
les grâces y avait bien de finalement
c'est le grand désert où est passée
cette crèche qu'on a déjà crié qu'on a
depuis 2000 c'est ce qu'on avait fait au
monde capot pourquoi ça ne se voit pas
il faut on à communiquer dans un début
2016 on dit bientôt
cette crèche va s'ouvrir alors pourquoi
mais là
une bulle où elle se trouve dans une
situation on fait des projets on le
laisse on ne suit pas et en plus on est
super man décès il faudra encore à
réfléchir sur l'endettement avec la
caisse des écoles et bien évidemment
avec le ccas c'est ça aussi la joie
colère ça c'est pour les missions bord
de sa moto au second tour il y à justin
pamphile qu'elle lève le projet qui me
tient le plus à coeur alors pour vous
c'est la situation est un peu compliquée
différentes que celles de vos
concurrents puisque vous êtes le maire
en place donc à désigner le montant de
votre ce que je veux dire aux
haut-rhinois j'entends des gens qui
parlent de projets il n'y a aucun
document à part le document que moi j'ai
transmis aux loups rhinois avec un
projet précis 33 actions cinq axes je
n'ai eu la connaissance d'aucun autre
projet a écrit adressé aux laurines vous
savez la parole passe c'est comme le
vent qui les emporte avec la poussière
et les cris reste les sang et or i au
feu et les crises en parler mais bon
wendy s'y adonnent ne pas nous
interrompre tous les jeux ne sont plus
tout à l'heure c'est parce qu'il avait
fait préalablement je continue la chaux
l'ol non non ça va tout va bien tout va
bien je dis c'est en présence de jean le
bon goût qui sur les missions qui vous
écoutent regardent je veux siffler je
veux simplement de la parole passe les
cuirs est et les écrits en gage j'ai
l'habitude depuis le temps où je me suis
engagé en politique à écrire à faire des
bilans à dire ce que je fais et a
également a écrit aux gens les projets
je les fais en 2008 je les fais en 2014
et gelé refait en 2020 les gens ont reçu
dans leur boîte aux lettres ils
reçoivent le projet et nous le
présentons pendant la campagne
électorale
je veux revenir simplement sur une chose
sur les projets ce sont des choses que
nous avons engagée et que nous
poursuivons j'ai parlé de cauchemar tout
à l'heure d'une somme actuellement les
travaux de creusement ont commencé et
les travaux vont aller jusqu'à leur
terme ses 6 millions 5 de travaux la
réhabilitation du à la voix de castel
brando pour permettre l'accès à la casse
à vis de la famille régal pour
désenclaver le quartier morne bois pour
permettre aux grands bus
d'arriver directement chez dans le
restaurant chez un bond de bois nous
sommes actuellement en train de
travailler dessus
la reconstruction la réhabilitation du
marché
la réhabilitation de catalan qui a
commencé la réhabilitation de la rue
ponton permettant d'accéder au cimetière
de refaire la voix ensuite j'ai entendu
dire qu'il n'y a pas d'accompagnement
des personnes dans les cités eh ben il y
actuellement une inaction qui est menée
par une association et qui est avec la
caisse d'allocations familiales ce sont
des espaces de vie sociale les espaces
de vie sociale notamment su au format sa
canne à sucre puis aux carabins nous
avons pris la décision d'étendre les
espaces de vie sociale sous les autres
quartiers
la halte-garderie puisque vous voulez
vous avez peut-être des petits enfants a
envoyé là bas
la halte-garderie aujourd'hui la plage
nature vous n'avez pas de petits enfants
des petits enfants j'ai dit non je n'ai
pas dit autre chose si vous avez ce que
ses petits enfants
la halte garderie est terminée au moment
où je vous parle la clé a été remise à
l'association qui gère la halte garderie
et il lui appartient aujourd'hui avec la
ville de mener les éléments pour pouvoir
l'inaugurer l'ouvrir et je peux
continuer je suis l'aspect culturel la
ville a déjà au moment où je vous parle
signé le schéma de développement
culturel pendant pour trois années
consécutives ou la médiathèque la salle
l'espace de diffusion
la maison de la culture la rénovation a
commencé nous allons la poursuivre
chaque année nous mettons 50000 euros
sur la maison de la culture et nous
allons poursuivre sa climatisation son
insonorisation et c'est là que je peux
continuer le problème c'est que si je
continue et peut-être que oui mais je me
suis dit je vais le faire pendant la
campagne
la seule chose que je peux dire c'est
que nous travaillons à l'argoat nous
travaillons à la fois sur les bâtiments
mais nous travaillons en simultané sur
également les personnes nous sommes
actuellement en train de signer une
convention avec inspire plus parce qu
inspire plus c'est une association qui
prend en charge les personnes qui ont
des difficultés sociales psycho
sociologiques et nous les accompagnons
nous le faisons non vous savez des fois
je vous dis quand je les écoute je me
demande s'ils sont au courant de ce qui
se passe dans la ville autant pour me
chalonnais qui lui à un moment donné
dans la vie associative est encore un
peu aujourd'hui
avec l'association coup de pouce mais
madame point fait lousiane je n'ai pas
souvenir ni connaissance de l'avoir vu
un seul jour de ma vie pendant tout le
temps où j'ai été dans la vie
associative est dans une association
john bales de football de pétanque ou
autre
donc quand on me parle de la vie
associative il filles étaient habitués
par le lorrain il faut connaître ce qui
se passe les viets en lorraine il faut
connaître ce qui se passe dans la vie
associative
il suffit simplement d'aller demander
aux associations qui existent depuis une
quarantaine d'années si un seul jouer un
seul moment
ces deux personnes ont oeuvré dans ces
associations de quartier merci ben c'est
pas un film nous sommes en arriver aux
conclusions
comme c'est maintenant panfilo diane qui
a été tiré au sort pour terminer cette
série de conclusions et bien la parole à
monsieur guy a donné en une minute
au départ j'ai tendu oui mais une
personne alizée pour votre conclusion
mes chers à l'horizon vous voyez que au
thème de ces émissions pour ne pas dire
à laver cette fin de campagne électorale
nous avons beaucoup entendu nous avons
beaucoup vu
il nous avons vu les manoeuvres et en
mettant un peu de tromper les
populations et la vigilance de la
population comme cela était déjà fait
depuis plusieurs fois où effectivement
c'est une litanie de projets
effectivement il ne s'engage qu'à
seulement à celui qui le fait en tout
cas on nous et un épilogue avec des
jeunes policiers
nous avons comme ambition de faire du
loing une ville qui se bat pour son
territoire il se bat notamment pour les
motivations de cette ville une ville
solidaire qui protège les plus fragiles
et les plus et sur le plan social une
ville fière de ses valeurs
vivre aux lorrains doit être pour nous
un lieu où il fait bon vivre une ville
attractive comme avant où les gens
venaient s'arrêtait et vivait une ville
qui protège son lustre d'antan par le
sport la culture et les loisirs mais
aussi une ville gérer en bon père de
famille alors mes chers amis de l'oim
c'est du concret ce que je dis je
le fait - oui c'est un oui mon projet
vous les aurez dans votre boîte aux
lettres très grand projet un bon projet
je vous demande de faire confiance à la
liste union des pilotes au loin
et puis avec des policiers à sa tête guy
annonay
je vous remercie guy annonay pour la
liste l'yonne et puis l'auteur pour
laurens est de retour pour sa conclusion
de justin pamphile le may en son temps à
la tête de la liste je vous retrouve mes
notes vous allez me le dire monsieur
profil ça voyons ensemble tranquillement
à construire le lauréat l'isi pour votre
conclusion
laurine oil haut-rhinoise vous me
connaissez je suis votre maire depuis
vous m'avez renouveler votre confiance
massivement en votant pour la liste que
je conduisais avec 3400 voix nous
permettant de poursuivre le travail que
nous avions commencé grâce à vos
suffrages qui nous ont aidés en tout cas
à concrétiser à cette norme de progemes
église que nous avions trouvé dans un
mauvais état
l'école léon cécile que nous avons
reconstruit et bon nombre de projets le
plan de relance qui nous a permis de
rénover la rue schoelcher de rénover la
rue gambetta de rénover la rue général
de gaulle le plan de relance qui nous a
permis de mettre en place de nombreux
chantiers d'insertion qui ont permis la
mise au travail de nos beaux jeunes du
territoire
le programme vaste que nous avons lancée
sur la construction de logements dans
les différents quartiers qui ont permis
le relogement de familles qui pendant un
certain nombre d'années ne trouvait
aucune solution pour leur permettre de
d'être logés dans leur ville et
justement parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
logés dans leur ville eh bien ils
partaient nous allons continuer le
travail que nous avons entamé
nous allons accentuer notre activité en
matière de logement en particulier pour
les seniors pour leur permettre de
rester dans leur ville
nous allons entame un grand chantier de
réhabilitation du centre bourg nous
allons prendre en compte dans nos
espaces de vie sociale nous allons
continuer l'embellissement parce que
nous avons obtenu notre première fleur
et nous allons chercher la deuxième la
troisième la quatrième fleur qui va
participer à l'aménagement et à
l'embellissement de la ville sûre que je
vais vous dire simplement vous me
connaissez quand je dis quelque chose je
le fais la pratique de cette équipe
c'est dire ce que nous faisons c'est
faire ce que nous disons
et c'est voir ce que nous avons fait je
dis aux lourds hino a simplement j'ai
autour de moi une équipe d'hommes et de
femmes qui sont déterminés qu'ils
veulent avancer pour continuer à
construire cette ville est bien le 15
mars dès le premier tour je leur demande
de nous accorder à nouveau leur
confiance pour que nous puissions
recommencer à travailler en sérénité
merci justin pamphile et enfin au tour
pour dernier en conclusion véronique
profil odienne à la tête de la liste
avion pour le loin bien à leurs chers
lecteurs chères lectrices du l'oral 15
mars prochain vous serez invité à
prendre une décision importante à savoir
est ce que vous voulez toujours resté
dans des 2 2 le béton est ce qu'on
consomme le béton ou alors est-ce que
vous souhaitez qu'il y ait véritablement
un projet tel que celui que les citoyens
une large partie des citoyens ont
proposé à savoir travailler sur les
hommes et les femmes construire le
lorrain de demain construire une société
parce que nous savons que les murs
peuvent tomber au moindre tremblement de
terre 1
évidemment donc si nous voulons
effectivement travailler sur une société
nous allons travailler sur les hommes et
sur les femmes mais aussi sur la
protection de notre biodiversité de
notre richesse au et également sur notre
agriculture donc très cher louis noir
très cher louis l'oise
nous vous invitons à intervenir dès le
15 mars dans les urnes parce qu'il faut
justement posé le bulletin de véronique
pons fille josiane qui permettra de
mettre en place la régie agricole
communal qui permettra de mettre en
place également le plan communal santé
mais également bientôt de très nombreux
projets sur la culture notamment est
également sur le sport donc à très
bientôt
soyez là avec nous dès le 15 mars
prochain ironiquement fils ou diane pour
agir pour le loin merci madame par phil
dowd yens pour votre conclusion c'est
ainsi que se termine ce débat entre les
candidates et les candidats du lorrain
sur une réalisation de jean louis bauer
le wind a lui-même qui me confiant que
il y a
les lobbys noël et les noiséens
tempérament vif peut-être est-ce dû à
communiquer via l'océan atlantique nous
projetons mais c'est de bon ton
je connais le natif du lourd et qui un
peu comme point d'attaquer ce débat est
à retrouver sur notre site internet
c'est le dernier de la série en radio
filmée mais demain mardi 10 mars vous
allez retrouver le dernier de la série
en télévision avec les candidates de
fort de france
nous nous retrouvons très bientôt à la
radio évidemment pour la journée la
soirée électorale ce sera dimanche 15
mars madame monsieur à bientôt élections
municipales martinique première
[Musique]